when we were doing Club promo some of
the boys would use the term like she's
Instagram hot does that mean she looks
fit on Instagram but in real life isn't
quite as hot but part of the hotness of
the girl on Instagram was impacting how
highly they regarded them in real life
because you've got kind of pre-selection
right if this girl's got more followers
than everybody else and everyone thinks
that she's really really fit online even
if she kind of isn't that in the real
world it's almost like a degree of
competence I call this the Tiffany
Sparks Theory and basically if you look
at two diamond rings that look identical
but one is from ziles and one is from
Tiffany's it is the same exact product
if I was to give you either one of those
rings and I like stuck in a paper bag
and I crumpled it up and I threw the
paper bag at you and then you got that
ring you're already pre-selected you
already have a bias to say what is this
this is like a fake ring but if I gave
you the $5,000 ring and I put it in the
Tiffany's box and I tied it up and I
presented it to you in this way you
would now value that ring at a $50,000
amount if we wrap something properly we
will consider it to be more valuable